[Música]
Argentina es la primera selección
latinoamericana en clasificarse a
cuartos de final del mundial y lo logró
tras vencer a Australia 2-1 en la
siguiente fase se enfrentará a Países
Bajos que hoy venció tres a uno a
Estados Unidos conectamos con Buenos
Aires
el presidente de ucraniano
de poco serios los límites que pusieron
el g7 y Australia al precio del petróleo
ruso hoy la Unión Europea formalizó la
restricción de fijar en un máximo de 60
dólares el barril que venga de Rusia
y beiji ya no tendrás cabinas de prueba
de Kobe 19 mientras que schen ya no será
necesario presentar un test negativo
para usar el transporte público estas
son algunas de las medidas que se
relajaron en China tras las protestas en
contra de la política de cero covid
Bienvenidos a la actualidad
internacional en France 24 yo soy María
Clara calle Gracias por estar con
nosotros e iniciamos con las noticias
del mundial después de un segundo tiempo
con bastante sustos para Argentina
finalmente la albiceleste clasificó a
cuartos de final tras derrotar dos a uno
a Australia así se conformó la primera
llave del siguiente grupo que enfrentará
a Países Bajos con los argentinos Vamos
hasta Buenos Aires donde está nuestro
corresponsal natalio cosoy natalio usted
está Precisamente en medio de la
celebración cuéntenos Cuál es el
ambiente
Hola Sí qué tal las celebraciones en una
de las tantas esquinas de Buenos Aires
donde bares pone en pantallas para ver
el partido hay varios lugares como este
donde la verdad entusiasmo ha sido
absoluto un poco de miedo sobre el final
en el segundo tiempo pero también muchos
sustos para Australia porque Argentina
estuvo muy cerca de convertir el tercero
en varias ocasiones Argentina jugó muy
bien que estaba muy contenta la gente
que veía el partido de la performance de
la selección la verdad que enfrentó en
Australia que en el inicio se plantó de
una forma ordenada para tratar de
detener la ofensiva Argentina mantuvo la
cabeza fría jugando la pelota por abajo
qué es lo que también sabe hacer hasta
encontrar los dos huecos primero en el
primer tiempo por parte de del lío Messi
y luego Julián Álvarez en el segundo
tiempo dándole la posibilidad Argentina
después de ese sustazo del gol de
Australia y el potencial segundo gol que
estuvo cerca de Argentina de pasar a
cuartos de final bueno Y usted
precisamente mencionó el gol de Leo
Messi el capitán argentino y quienes sin
duda el centro de atención qué tal va el
10 en este mundial y que él espera la
selección ante Países Bajos
aquí le
cantas jugando su partido número 1000
como profesional Y está cerca de
alcanzar el récord de récord de goles de
selección nacional Argentina está un gol
de alcanzar ese récord en Argentina jugó
muy bien Lio Messi encontrando cada vez
más un rol definido Claro en el equipo
de Argentina por supuesto en la próxima
etapa es un equipo más sólido que el de
Australia por lo menos en los papeles el
de Países Bajos un equipo que llegó
cómodo después del partido de la fecha y
que además en la historia que comparten
en en mundiales hay una paridad de la
historia cambia porque los equipos
también cambian las conformaciones
cambian paso a paso por el entusiasmo es
muy grande ya veremos si me decía
alcanzar ese récord gracias natalio por
su reporte cambiamos de noticia y
también de lugar vamos a Ucrania porque
el país comienza a celebrar la Navidad
de una manera austera sin muchas luces a
causa de la crisis energética mientras
que en Francia el presidente de Manuel
mahon hizo un llamado a la Calma
referencia a los posibles cortes de luz
el informe es de Manuela Cano
una plaza vacía Y una promesa de
austeridad Jeff recibe la temporada
navideña sin luces ni adornos el centro
de la capital ucraniana suele hacer gala
de un enorme árbol de navidad de más de
30 metros esta vez ante los ataques
rusos a la infraestructura ucraniana su
tamaño se verá reducido a más de la
mitad y estará adornado con símbolos del
ejército ucraniano una muestra simbólica
de la crisis energética que vivió
Ucrania y Europa la llegada de un
invierno inusual preocupa al viejo
continente en donde se han anunciado
posibles cortes de Electricidad Y aunque
el panorama parece gris las autoridades
de algunos países europeos hacen un
llamado a la calma No entren en pánico
eso no tiene sentido
hay un trabajo legítimo realizado por el
gobierno para prepararse para casos
extremos que es por supuesto la
necesidad de cortar la electricidad
durante algunas horas en el día Es
normal que el gobierno se prepare para
un caso extremo porque como nos han
demostrado los últimos años a veces
sucede lo impensable
en paralelo Europa Busca soluciones
Bélgica inaugura la mayor planta de
almacenamiento de energía eléctrica de
Europa continental afuera de una pequeña
ciudad belga estos contenedores son
capaces de satisfacer la demanda máxima
del país un paso hacia la transición
energética hasta ahora la capacidad de
producir rápidamente significaba muchas
centrales eléctricas de petróleo o
centrales eléctricas de gas que
activamos en cualquier momento con este
nuevo tipo de Central eléctrica es
posible prescindir por completo de los
combustibles fósiles ante una posible
crisis energética la comisión europea
planteó Establecer un tope para los
precios de gas en toda la Unión Europea
una determinación que ha generado
choques entre los ministros de energía
de muchos de los países miembros
precisamente hoy la comisión Europea
formalizó el acuerdo que lograron el g7
y Australia ayer para ponerle un precio
máximo de 60 dólares al barril de
petróleo ruso Aunque occidente dice que
así mirará la fuerza de Moscú en la
guerra el presidente u
no estuvo del todo de acuerdo porque
dice que el límite le da margen de
maniobra a Rusia escúchanos
Esta es una posición débil y es solo
cuestión de tiempo antes de que se
tengan que usar herramientas más fuertes
de todos modos es una pena que esta vez
se pierda la lógica es obvia si el
precio límite para el petróleo ruso es
de 60 dólares en lugar de por ejemplo 30
como lo expresaron en particular Polonia
y los países bálticos Entonces el
presupuesto ruso recibirá alrededor de
100 mil millones de dólares por año este
dinero se destinará no solo a la guerra
y no solo al patrocinio de Rusia de
otros regímenes y organizaciones
terroristas diferentes
china comienza a relajar su política de
cero covid que fue el objeto de las
críticas de las protestas de la semana
pasada las restricciones sean
flexibilizado en algunas ciudades como
Beijing en la capital por ejemplo ya no
se exigirá un resultado negativo para
entrar a lugares como supermercados Y es
que las manifestaciones contra las
restricciones fueron tan fuertes que a
veces incluso pidieron la renuncia del
presidente algo que no se había visto
[Música]
estas fueron las protestas que
desconcertaron al mundo después de tres
años de ansios masivos y pruebas
constantes los ciudadanos frustrados
salieron a la calle en manifestaciones
generalizadas que el país No había visto
en décadas
beijinga señalado que una
flexibilización amplia de la política
cero covid podría estar en marcha ya que
las ciudades se preparan para suavizar
las restricciones esta decisión fue
recibida con alivio por parte de la
población
creo que la gente se alegra de que se
suavice la política porque reduce el
impacto en la vida de las personas
todos mis amigos piensan que tras la
reapertura Seguiremos necesitando cierta
protección diaria y que deberemos
abastecernos de algunos medicamentos en
casa así si alguien tiene síntomas no
tendrá que ir al hospital
el presidente del Consejo europeo
la cuestión de las protestas a
sí acusó los jóvenes frustrados de
desatar las protestas y sugirió que ya
que la cepa omicron es menos letal las
políticas del país podrían suavizarse la
flexibilización de las normas contra el
Coby 19 en algunas ciudades fue bien
acogida por la Organización Mundial de
la Salud
nos complace saber que las autoridades
chinas están Ajustando sus estrategias
actuales y realmente tratan de calibrar
ahora las medidas de control que
necesitan para este virus con las vidas
los sustentos y los Derechos Humanos de
las personas en las comunidades
las nuevas políticas podrían incluir más
vacunaciones pruebas no obligatorias
autocuarrentena en lugar de cierres
masivos y la flexibilización de las
normas sobre el transporte público pero
por ahora los residentes aún no han
presenciado un cambio sobre el terreno
suspendió a la radio rfi de Francia
nuestra cadena hermana el gobierno
militar calificó al medio de emitir
informes falsos y darle voz a los
militantes islamistas Y todo porque rfi
transmitió un mensaje de un líder de un
grupo militante el medio no ha
respondido oficialmente hasta ahora no
es el primer país en expulsar a la radio
pública internacional francesa Mali hizo
lo mismo en marzo en medio de las
relaciones deterioradas entre París y
las antiguas colonias de África
occidental por la frustración ante la
falta de resultados contundentes por
parte de los militares franceses en
contra de los IRS insurgentes en el
y así llegamos al final de las noticias
sigan con France 24
[Música]